thank you
I love meeting people organically
locking eyes with you somewhere and
being like Oh
and I actually just found someone really
cute all right done can we call a game
oh take a shot
I don't need another shot what's up hi
yeah yeah
so you're from out here I was born and
racing oh yeah half a Reuben
yeah one of my best friends gave Verdian
not many people are familiar with that
so that's fun
yeah
I've always been sexually attracted to
women My First Kiss was actually with a
girl I was probably 14. I remember I had
a girls night and one of the girls had
already like kissed a lot so I remember
her like kissing us so like we could
like practice kissing and ever since
then I've wanted to do more
and right now while I'm single
why not why haven't I
you're so you just came down into Aruba
yeah like on a winter vacation Welcome
to our Paradise yeah
I love it the people are good The Vibes
are good
I'm loving it out here
oh gosh it's hot it is really hot so
yeah
are you dating anyone no I'm not dating
anyone I'm single now and I don't know
I'm just out here exploring okay okay
yeah
have you ever been married I've never
met engaged but yeah oh you're engaged
engaged to be married
yeah that's what's up
damn
it was nice meeting you I'm gonna go
grab a drink do your thing do you want
one do you want to go grab a drink let's
go ahead all right let's go let's have
some fun why not yes
Daphne telling me that she's engaged I'm
very disappointed
but I was proud of myself for still
going over and still trying to flirt
salute
pursuing women is Uncharted Territory
for me
but
the real has been cast
and I'll know who I'm reeling in yet
[Music]